♪ ♪ ♪
- Mikhaïl Baryshnikov, bonjour.
- Bonjour.
- Mikhaïl Baryshnikov,
vous êtes une légende
de la danse contemporaine.
Vous êtes en pleine répétition
pour la nouvelle version
du "Fusil de chasse" de François
Girard, qui sera présentée ici,
à New York, à compter du 15 mars
prochain. Qu'est-ce qui vous a
intéressé dans ce projet-là.
♪ ♪ ♪
Pour la petite histoire,
vous étiez un des élèves
prodiges du chorégraphe
Aldrdrdre Pouchkine et vous avez
fui l'Union soviétique en 1974
et vous avez trouvé refuge au
Canada. Quelle place le Canada
occupe dans votre coeur?
♪ ♪ ♪
Sur scène, vous avez triomphé
daenenentre autres, "Gisèle".
Au cinéma, on vous a vu
dans "The Turning Point",
mais aussi dans "White Nights",
et vous avez vraiment étéununune
la liberté artistique.
Qu'est-ce que ça représente
pour vous, cette liberté?
♪ ♪ ♪
Il y a un an, jour pour jour,
aujourd'hui, la Russie attaquait
l'Ukraine. Vous êtes né en Union
soviétique. J'imagine que
c'est une journée symbolique.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle représente?
Mikhaïl Baryshnikov,
merci pour cet entretien.
- Avec plaisir.
♪ ♪ ♪